Eleven's secret connection to the monsters
of the Upside Down is finally revealed in
Season 4, with a huge twist.
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers, I'm Jan and this
is the ending of Stranger Things Season 4
Part 1 explained, plus predictions and theories
for the second part and how to defeat Vecna.
Spoilers, of course, so take care.
The fourth season kicks off in horrific fashion
revealing that in 1979, there was a brutal
massacre at the Hawkins Lab, with Eleven the
only apparent survivor.
This sets up the idea that El was the one
who carried out the attack.
As the season unfolds and we see her smash
bully Angela in the face at the skating rink,
it's implied that Eleven was exacting revenge
on Two and the other test subjects who bullied
her.
What if I am the monster?
Eleven's memories of that fateful day though
are missing.
So, when she reunites with Papa and Dr Owens
at the Nina Project, she's able to re-experience
her early days at the lab and remembers one
of the orderlies who was friendly to her.
It turns out that he's actually Number One,
and his special abilities were being suppressed
via an implant in his neck.
Unaware of this, Eleven pulls the implant
out, and he then uses his powers to lethal
effect on a team of guards who've come to
catch them.
One also snaps the final guard's neck, just
like Eleven did in Season 1.
We're alike.
You and I.
Eleven then discovers that it was One who
slaughtered everyone at Hawkins Lab that day,
and the reveal is a double-twist because it
also turns out that he's Victor Creel's son,
Henry.
And though we don't see him till later on
in the season, early in the first episode,
Brenner mentions him by the name he goes by
at the lab, Peter.
Peter, Alec, what's going on out there?
The Creels had moved to Hawkins in search
of a fresh start for their troubled boy who
teachers and doctors had all described as
"broken".
There he took an interest in a nest of Black
Widow spiders in the house, and his admiration
for them as predators and "gods of our world"
points to his megalomaniac desire to rule
over and change the world.
Humans are a unique type of pest, multiplying
and poisoning our world.
I could not do that.
And I realized I could make my own rules.
I could restore balance to a broken world.
A predator...
but for good.
What's especially interesting is that Henry
already possessed powerful abilities before
he even ended up in Hawkins Lab, and they
don't appear to be the result of any experiments.
As he developed his psychic powers, he found
he could reach into people's memories and
discover some of the terrible things they'd
done or experienced in their lives.
This is similar to Eleven's abilities to perform
remote viewing on subjects across huge distances
such as the Russian spy in Season 1 or when
she reached into the memories of Billy's abusive
childhood in Season 3.
Unlike Eleven though, the Creel boy decided
to use his power to punish his family for
what he saw as their transgressions, killing
his mother and sister, leaving the blame on
his father who ended up locked away for murder.
Henry was secretly sent to Hawkins Lab, where
Papa decided to exploit him to recreate his
exceptional powers in others, branding him
with a Number One tattoo.
Like many interesting villains, the show may
be trying to elicit some sympathy for him
when we see how the lab appears to be abusing
him with electro-shock torture.
However, given One's murder of his family
and indiscriminate massacre at the lab, he's
clearly delusional in his thinking that he's
doing good.
And when he asks El, Darth Vader-style, to
join him to take down the evil Emperor Brenner...
You are better than they are.
That is why you frighten him.
We could reshape the world, remake it.
Join me.
No.
As they face off, El tries to summon the power
to resist him, using the advice One gave her
to recall a memory of something that made
her sad and angry, something similar to what
Kali recommended to Eleven in Season 2.
I want you to find something that angers you.
So, it seems that One may have manipulated
Kali as well.
The advice though isn't enough for the young
El to withstand One's incredibly strong powers
and, as he's about to kill her, Eleven has
a memory of her own birth come flooding into
her brain.
Jane, I love you.
Instead of anger, it's this memory of love
which gives Eleven the strength to reverse
One's imminent victory, and she smashes him
through the glass into the wall behind, and
follows it with a nice little superhero landing.
By the way, Brenner had already advised not
to give into anger a few days earlier.
If you allow anger or emotion to invade your
thoughts, you will fail.
The young El then dusts him into the Upside
Down, just like she did with the Demogorgon
in Season 1.
Both scenes are also an X-Men easter egg to
Jean Grey, who defeated the villain Mastermind
in this way, and the comic book in which that
happened was specifically referenced in the
opening scene of the pilot episode.
I'll take your X-Men 134!
It was also a cool detail how Eleven sent
One crashing through the mirrored glass into
the room behind, foreshadowing how, moments
later, she literally sends him through the
wall into another dimension.
And as he tumbles down, bursts of lightning
strike his body, transforming him into Vecna.
This big reveal that One is Vecna more or
less confirms a number of fan theories that
the original test subject at Hawkins Lab is
connected to the Upside Down and its various
villains like the Mind Flayer or the Demogorgon.
And, similar to how the Mind Flayer monster
in Season 3 was created by melting and joining
together the bodies of its victims, One mentions
a couple of times how he seems to have absorbed
the people he's killed.
With each life I took, I grew stronger.
They were becoming a part of me.
They're not gone, Eleven.
They're still with me.
In here.
In fact, Vecna sometimes asks his targets
or victims to join him as he tries to feed
off their misery or sorrow, which reminds
me a little of how Pennywise feeds off people's
fear.
We can also see some of the bodies he's collected
in the Upside Down version of the Creel House,
such as Nancy's reporter colleague Fred.
Vecna is also connected to the Upside Down's
hive mind, giving him the ability to spy with
any of the monsters under his control.
This is similar to how the Mind Flayer used
Will as a spy in Season 2 and Billy as a spy
and pawn in Season 3.
So when Steve, Nancy, Robin and Eddie cycle
through the Upside Down on their way to find
the gate where Chrissy died, a Demobat spots
them and screeches, and we see Vecna reacting
as he can now track what the group are up
to.
This is why when Nancy tries to go through
the gate to return to the real world, before
she can get across, Vecna is able to intercept
her by entering her consciousness and putting
her under his curse.
When Nancy falls into Vecna's lair, we can
see how the villain preys on his victims'
fear and guilt over the traumatic events in
their lives.
So, for Nancy, she falls into the swimming
pool at Steve's house where Barb was killed
by the Demogorgon in Season 1.
This plays on Nancy's feelings of guilt about
how Barb died alone at the pool, while she
was hooking up with Steve inside.
Nancy is now mentally trapped by Vecna, akin
to what happened to Max when she visited Billy's
grave.
In that case, when Dustin and co played Max's
favourite song, it broke through to her, creating
an opening, an opportunity to escape.
Max combines that with recalling happy memories
of her time in Hawkins which gives her the
strength to break free of Vecna's grip.
I expect Nancy may need some similar help,
given that Vecna may also prey on her guilt
over her re-kindled feelings for Steve, perhaps
accusing her of being unfaithful to Jonathan.
Ok, we have to talk about Hopper now that
Joyce and Murray have broken him out of the
Russian prison, and there's a huge clue in
Season 4 about how they'll return home now
that Yuri's plane has crashed.
But, just before that, I want to thank the
sponsor of this video Skillshare.
I often get asked how I discover all the details
and easter eggs in my videos, and a lot comes
down to understanding the nuts and bolts of
filmmaking.
Skillshare have an amazing array of classes
where you can learn all the techniques and
tricks that go into creating the look of incredible
shots like this one in Stranger Things.
For example, this course on cinematography
explains in just 30 minutes how a professional
filmmaker sets the mood, tone and feel of
a scene.
And this screenwriting class will help you
appreciate and learn how to write a mind-bending
plot-driven film like Arrival.
Skillshare also has a ton of other creative
classes you can take from photography to graphic
design, video editing, and character animation.
So, if you want to pivot your career or level-up
your existing skills, Skillshare is the perfect
resource to beef up your CV and learn a new
side hustle.
How about this course on how to launch yourself
on Tiktok, for example?
As a very special offer, the first 1,000 people
to use the link or my code FLICKS will get
a one month free trial of Skillshare.
Click the link below to get one month completely
free!
OK, back to Hop.
Although I'm sure we're all relieved he and
Dmitri survived their encounter with the Demogorgon,
there's still the pesky problem of how on
earth they're going to get back to the US.
Yuri's plane crash-landed so there's no easy
way to get back to North America.
However, there's a big clue on one of the
Season 4 posters which shows Hopper, Joyce
and Murray approaching a gate to the Upside
Down inside the Russian prison.
We know from Season 3 that the Russians opened
a gate themselves.
In the Season 4 sneak-peek, there's a shot
of Hop going through a door with a flaming
weapon and I think this is him returning to
the prison in search of the gate and armed
with fire in case they encounter the Demogorgon.
In fact, there's a special Volume 2 teaser
on Netflix that plays right after the end
of the seventh episode credits which reveals
even more Hopper details.
He enters a room with caged Demogorgons, though
it's not clear whether they're alive or dead.
And then he and Murray stumble upon a glass
box filled with black particulates which appear
to be like the black mist the Mind Flayer
used to possess Will in the second season.
An interesting detail about Hopper's past
came up this season when he revealed new details
about the tragic backstory of his daughter's
death.
Hop explains to Dmitri that when he was in
Vietnam, he was heavily exposed to Agent Orange,
a chemical used by the U.S. against the Viet
Cong during the war.
And Hopper goes on to explain the horrors
of what happened when veterans from the war
later had children.
Kids born stillborn.
Dead in the womb.
Crooked spines, eyes popped out.
That last point is especially chilling because
it's the same way that One or Vecna murders
his victims, twisting their limbs and gouging
their eyes out.
And, given the importance of the Rainbow Room
in the Stranger Things mythology, it can't
be just a coincidence that the Duffer Brothers
came up with this particular storyline as
Agent Orange is classified by the U.S. military
as a Rainbow Herbicide,
in other words it was used in warfare, which
reminds me of the times that Eleven, a product
of the Rainbow Room, has been referred to
as a weapon over the seasons.
She's a weapon!
Her baby's a weapon, off fighting the commies.
In fact, the unethical use of chemicals for
military and other purposes is a recurring
theme in the series.
The Hawkins Lab was part of Project MKUltra,
a real-life CIA illegal operation that experimented
with various psychedelic drugs and other chemicals
on subjects as part of biological warfare
research.
And in Season 3, both human and rat victims
of the Mind Flayer consumed toxic amounts
of fertiliser and chemicals so that their
bodies would be physically weakened, and they
would break down and melt easily before becoming
part of the Spider Monster.
Hopper feels a huge sense of guilt about the
fact he knew he'd been exposed to Agent Orange
and still decided to have a baby with his
wife.
I knew the risks, but I hid them.
And he believes he sentenced Sara to death
because of this
Everyone I love, I hurt.
I wasn't cursed.
I am the curse.
And Hop's words have clear parallels with
how his adopted daughter El sees herself as
a monster at various points as well.
I am a monster.
Hopper's feelings of guilt are likely to come
back to haunt him in the second part of this
season as Vecna could easily put him under
a curse by reminding him of this.
I also think that Eddie could very well end
up sacrificing himself for the group by the
end of Volume 2.
He specifically brought up the point that
he's not normally very brave:
Outside of D&D, I am no hero.
I see danger and I just turn heel and run.
However, in the Season 4 trailer, there's
footage of him playing his guitar on top of
a trailer in the Upside Down with a set of
loudspeakers playing at maximum volume.
Sorry I'm late, sweetheart.
[strums notes]
You're beautiful.
This may be to blast out music in an effort
to break Nancy out of her trance, but it's
also very dangerous as it will inevitably
attract attention from the Demobats and, in
turn, Vecna.
And in the Volume 2 teaser, there's footage
that reveals Nancy seemingly free with Robin
and Steve wearing camouflage.
Some more shots in the trailer and volume
2 teaser we haven't yet seen are this one
of Erica in the Upside Down, and another of
Dustin who's also in the alternate dimension.
There's this shot of Eleven standing in front
of the Nina Project as it blows up, and Mrs
Wheeler and Holly terrified of something.
Comment below if you have any theories on
what might be going on in these shots.
There's also the mystery of Will's painting.
Will is painting a lot, but he won't show
me what he's working on.
Maybe it is for a girl.
I think there is someone he likes, because
he has been acting weird.
Uh, what's that?
Um, it's nothing.
Just this painting I've been working on.
Will also grabs it in the fourth episode before
they have to escape with Argyle, so it's clearly
important.
We know Will has been possessed by the Mind
Flayer previously, and he drew a map of all
the vast tunnel network the monster had created
beneath Hawkins.
So I strongly suspect this painting will hold
a crucial clue to defeating Vecna.
Eleven regaining her powers is also surely
crucial to defeating the villain, and now
that she's remembered what really happened
at the Lab, perhaps she'll get some more answers
from Brenner.
She did briefly regain her powers at one point,
but then they immediately disappeared.
You didn't think it would be that easy, did
you?
I don't understand.
I do.
Papa.
Daughter.
The eighth and next episode is titled "Papa",
so I expect we'll get some answers and progress
with Eleven there.
There's a stack of more details in Season
4 we need to discuss, which I'll do in my
next video, so make sure you subscribe and
hit the bell to get notified as soon as that's
ready.
So, Movie Lovers, what do you think of Season
4 so far?
And what are your predictions for the final
two episodes out on the 1st of July?
Tap left for my next Stranger Things theory
and easter egg video.
And if you liked this video, do leave a thumbs-up,
I really appreciate it.
Bitchin', right?
Yeah, yeah.
Bitchin'.
Thanks for enjoying Stranger Things with me
and hope you have a marvellous movie-loving
week!
Yippee-ki-yay, movie lovers!